were so boring happy Wednesday
everybody except you so America
continues to suffer from a tragic
shortage of white racists oh they have
plenty of others but we're running low
on the pale faces it's gotten so bad our
media Bottom Feeders have to keep making
them up in the latest fake smear a hack
at sports site dead spin alleged that a
child with his face painted in his
football team colors was actually
blackface you know blackace right it's
that thing only Lefty celebs can get
away with oh and also Bugs
Bunny thank God that son of a
retired but with dead spin a funny thing
happened instead of getting the approval
that most woke media Karen's generally
batkin the scumbag Rider had to face the
new community notes function of Elon
musk's EX in record time Community notes
showed the kids full photo not just the
half painted black and so the only thing
this kid is guilty of is being
adorable we'll be right
back instead of a young Clansman in
training we see a kid wearing the colors
of his favorite team and now thanks to a
madeup charge of blackface the folks at
dead spin are guilty of egg
face yeah having egg on their
face I came up with that now you would
have thought that the Indian headdress
the kid was wearing at a Chief's game
might have been the tip off uh but for
Whitey hater Karen Phillips who just
made himself the Jesse Smet of sports
journalism it didn't matter cuz let's
face it this Karen knew what he was
doing he works for a Sports website for
God's sake he knows football fans often
have their faces painted in team colors
it's only been in every beer commercial
for the last 30 years still the piece's
headline claims the young fan was in
blackface and doubling up on racism
Phillips added that quote this is what
happens when you ban books stand against
critical race Theory and try to erase
centuries of hate you give future
Generations the ammunition they need to
evolve and recreate racism better than
before Oh first of all Banning books
wouldn't affect this nutbag since all he
can read are BLM protest
signs hell there's enough hogwash in
there to bathe Joy
bayar I
know I would I feel the same way it's a
lesson to us all so yeah a young kid
wearing his favorite team colors creates
racism better than before and accusing a
child of that is how you're erasing hate
Karen
you you're causing hate with a false
smear but it gets worse for him and dead
spin apparently the kid's not only a big
CH big Chiefs fan he's actually native
American
himself the boy's Mom confirmed it in
the kid's dad is reportedly a member of
the chumas tribe in California I think
that's the one Liz Warren is also a
member
[Applause]
of and the kids Granddad is reportedly
on the governing board of the Chumash
Indian Nation ah I bet that kid's name
is painted one sees you in
courts by the way according to the
National Park's website the Chumash
Indians engage in faced painting and
their colors red black and white so is
this an obvious case of an untalented
attention realizing this is the
only way he can gain notoriety sure so
let's give it to him Karen the only
reason you have a by line is because
you're a race baader no one would know
you if not for that and you exploited an
innocent child to amplify your pathetic
presence your stance isn't one of depth
or of substance it's just a vomit of
robotic cliché stolen from another
brainwashed clone I hope this story
follows you to the end of your very
brief
career now sure you can applaud I'll
take it gives me time to relax now this
isn't the first time young kids been
called racist by the media last month a
middle schooler was suspended for
wearing face paint support of his school
football team that damn racism shortage
again then there's the Covenant kids who
the media tried to turn into a clan
field rally only to discover that they
were wrong but because back then X was
the Lefty Echo chamber Twitter without
the community notes and Elon the kids
had to sue to fix the record and they
did and they won Nick Sandman has so
much money he could have bought CNN but
then he'd be paying
himself and yet has the woke media
learned anything other than how to
replace George Floyd with Palestine
here's Karen after being called out on x
quote for the idiots treating this as
some harmless act because the other side
was of his face was painted red I could
make the argument that it makes even
worse y'all are the ones who hate
Mexicans but wear some brero on
cinko I don't know what he's saying have
you agree with that you might have a
future at dead spin but actually you
probably won't because there's no future
at dead spin their spin is dying dead
spin has yet to issue an apology or
retraction and that's because the Sports
media in general has lost its balls the
woke scared them so they let the virus
in and take over and of course they
expected no blowback from their
like-minded media allly
but have you checked ESPN's ratings
lately they're lower than Bryant
stelter's Book
[Laughter]
Sales never over yeah I should have said
balls lower than his balls that would
have been funnier and weird because you
would know yeah that's true and look at
poor Sports Illustrated apparently the
rag had been publishing product reviews
by authors who didn't exist and were
written by AI SI have since blamed that
on a third party company but what do you
expect from a once great company who
succumbed to this and
this then there's ESPN who've given us
tons of woke moments the onair moment of
silence to protest Florida's parental
rights Bill the Talking Heads bashing
players for refusing to wear Pride
patches they even revived the debunk
story about a noose in a NASCAR garage
and who can forget that they gave race
biter Jamal Hill a job the bottom line
sports brands are zombie shells hollowed
out by the woke but now things may be
changing thanks to the left's great
Satan Elon Musk creating Community notes
a kid's life won't be destroyed seeus
created a way to prevent small false
smears from taking root he disabled the
one weapon that the left so desperately
embraced taking something out of context
sharing it with like-minded creeps and
letting it spread must killed that no
wonder they hate his guts they
should period let
welcome tonight's guest no one can
resist this former attorney's appeal
host of The True foxu Crime
[Applause]
podcast sadly hobos offer him money
founder of the lofas party.com Michael
Loftus she's like Saran rap thin clingy
and can fit in a drawer New York Times
bestselling author and fox contributor
that
too and he'll debate your points while
dislocating your joints New York Times
bestselling author comedian and former
NWA world champion
Tyrant you know Michael as a street
person AKA hobo transient people often
think you're in blackface when it's just
soot dirt and grind yeah cleaning out
chimneys for extra money yeah I know
exactly sleeping under a dumpster are
you surprised that they doubled down on
their claims I I think they have to
because uh the lawsuit is going to be so
big I mean it's going to be so huge and
I I just want to just applaud the
parents it's the way this is unfolding
it's beautiful it's like uh you ever
seen those glitter bombs that the people
leave on their porch yeah right it's
just a it's like a Amazon box but full
of glitter somebody steals it and it
blows up and makes a huge mess that's
what this feels like cuz this dude from
dead spin had to be so excited oh
there's a white kid in black face oh and
he's wearing a headdress and he's doing
the tomahawk chop yeah stop the presses
yeah and then to find out uhoh it's an
Indian kid uh-oh uh his dad's a member
of the tribe oh his grandfather is one
of the elders it's just going to keep
getting worse I I wanted to find out
like oh and his great grandmother
handcarved the Underground Railroad and
and was married to Harriet Tubman I want
it to get worse and worse and worse
maybe it will you know Emily you cheered
for the Raiders back in your previous
life uh plenty of fans painted their
faces at Raiders games can you believe
that dead spin didn't know of this trend
and that the photos that they chose to
publish were of only that one side of
the kid um yeah my my issue with this
actually the more that I think about it
the less I put any type of judgment
because I I love to judge otherwise but
any type of sort of onus on on that
author Karen Phillips because everything
he has ever written has been extremist
incendiary race baiting and absolute
nonsense my issue is with the publisher
my issue is with the amplification
process here that keeps giving him a
voice so much louder than everyone else
that has common sense that is trying to
diffuse this absolute and utter
unacceptable driil that we are continued
to be subjected to and my issue is also
with all of those decisions makers who
listen to that the NFL has now pledged
$250 million over the course of 10 years
to combat racism and put in the end
zones not only things like play football
no but also things like you know we all
we all need this together and end racism
as if that's going to do anything what
would do something is stop giving people
like Karen Phillips any platform shut
him up and the race fting would
actually I don't want him I don't want
him to be shut up cat if he shuts up I
run out of an a block for my
show I mean this guy has we've now done
three segments on this two on the five I
think I think he's on the fox payroll
cat yeah I thought yeah I I just I had
no idea you could get paid to write
articles about kids you don't
like I can't believe this I agree with
Emily I can't believe this was published
because it the way he conducted himself
was very much
as if he were a you know drug addled man
on the train like that kid something
like that kid is an like
somebody do something about that kid
people like hey man leave the kid alone
oh yeah well you hate
[Laughter]
Mexicans and this is a published work it
blows my mind and it couldn't have he's
probably thinking to himself you know
how was I supposed to know that this kid
was Native American well you know you're
not supposed to write that about a kid
yeah that's not a normal reaction he was
writing as if he was speaking truth to
power in some way and the power is like
5 years old exactly exactly so weird it
for a grown man to be going after a
small Elementary School at the oldest
probably child but you know what you
what you hit on here is that if you're
talking about groups of people it's not
about the child it's about the group he
represents so you can go after any
anybody including a 5-year-old child or
however old he is I can never tell the
age of kids probably a bad thing no I'm
very I am an expert I am an actual
expert at aging children because I count
down the years to M are 18 so I'm very
good that's when the child support stops
so I'm I'm like a
mathematician he's about
six I think you're all missing the the
point and the ugliness of this is not
just the idiot because you made a great
point you said the group and it's the
group that there's a certain group that
you're allowed to do this to white
people you can be racist and horrible as
you want to be as long as the group
you're racist against is white people he
doesn't have to apologize he won't
apologize his publisher won't stop him
we see this all the time now they've
gotten so desperate that now kids aren't
off limits they they usually would go
after adults we just saw the story two
weeks ago where a kid went to a high
school football game and he put two
black lines down his face and he was
expelled and could never go to a game
again because he wore a black face
they're so angry that they're that
they're R they're slipping through their
fingers the difference is now is that
white people are standing up but here's
what upset me I don't care that he's
Native American I don't care if that kid
was so white he was from Norway which I
established last night
he has every right to put on a headdress
and dress up like his favorite player
good
point and I'll just and I'll and I'll
end it with this I myself my favorite
basketball team is the Boston Celtics
and their mascots of leprechaun and
that's why I'm so kind to Greg
all I am a little bit
Irish uh I'm just thinking about my pot
of gold
all right before we go a quick
reminder I'll be in Albany Albany New
York this Sunday December 3rd for the
final stop on my book tour go to
ggutfeld.com for Ticket info hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else